[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name's Reto Meier, and I'm
the tech lead for Google's
Android Developer
Relations team.
This is the first of a series
of DevBytes created to help
you improve the battery
efficiency of your apps by
changing the way you handle
your data transfers.
The mobile cell radio is one
of the biggest sources of
battery drain on modern
smartphones, so making sure
transfers use it efficiently can
make a dramatic difference
to your app's impact on
the battery life.
Now on the surface,
this seems like a
pretty simple challenge.
If the cell radio drains the
battery, just transfer as
little data as possible, as
infrequently as possible.
Now that's a good start, but we
want to balance that with
providing a great user
experience, one where the data
your users need is available
as soon as they need it
without them ever needing
to hit refresh.
Now that requires understanding
how to optimize
the timing of your data
transfers, and that means
understanding the cell
state machine.
In order to conserve power, the
cell radio isn't kept on
permanently.
In fact, it goes through a
series of state transitions in
order to compromise between
low-latency data transfers and
minimizing the impact
on battery life.
It begins over here on standby
mode, where it's storing
minimal power until an app
initiates a data transfer.
At this point, it transitions to
full-power mode, a process
that takes around two
seconds, before
performing the transfer.
Rather than dropping back to
standby immediately after the
transfer is completed, the
radio will remain in full
power mode for a set tail time,
just in case further
transfers are initiated
within that window.
This happens because dropping
to a low-power state
reintroduces this power-up
latency.
Not only that, but transitioning
between states,
in and of itself, is a
significant power drain.
If nothing happens during the 5
to 10 second tail time, the
radio drops to this intermediate
low-power state
that uses less battery than full
power, but has a lower
startup latency than standby.
If a new transfer is initiated,
it will be promoted
back to full-power mode.
And if nothing happens for
another 30 seconds to a
minute, it'll drop
back to standby.
The exact latencies and tail
times vary between carriers,
or even within carriers
depending on where they are as
carriers try to balance low
latency with longer battery
life based on things like cell
congestion and typical
prevailing network conditions.
To understand how this might
affect your app design
choices, you start with this
simple equation, then take the
square root of the sum of the
latency and idle times between
each state, and then throw
all of that out.
Because it really doesn't
require any math to do.
And it doesn't even matter what
the specific latency or
tail times are for any
users of your app.
The solution comes down to what
I like to call the Cookie
Droid Conundrum.
When scheduling downloads, do
you transfer as much as you
can as infrequently as possible,
minimizing the
number of transfers at the
expense of bandwidth?
Or do you take the opposite
approach, transferring as
little as possible, performing
transfers more frequently?
Well, on the surface,
the "Little Cookie"
model appears sound.
Less data transferred means less
bandwidth and less time
spent with the radio active
to transfer our data.
And because we're downloading
what we need on demand, we
never download and process
more than we need.
Unfortunately, this results in
a heavily fragmented use of
the cell radio.
From our knowledge of the cell
radio state machine, we know
that every time we perform a
data transfer, the radio stays
active for at least 5 seconds
of tail time at full power,
followed by anywhere from 10 to
60 seconds at lower power
before it finally returns
to standby.
That means every time you
initiate a transfer, you're
powering the cell radio up
for at least 20 seconds.
Now we look at this more
closely, you can see how an
app like this one, whose radio
use is indicated here, can
drain the battery without
transferring very much data.
Each of these small peaks
represents something like
analytics data being sent back
to the server every 15
seconds, while the larger
peaks, they represent
intermittent transfers based
on user interaction, maybe
clicking on a news article
or looking at
a restaurant listing.
Now beneath that, we can see
how this affects the radio
state machine, with blue showing
active transfer times,
the rate indicating the radio
remaining in full power mode,
yellow, showing lower power
mode, and the gaps between,
showing us where the
radio is idle.
Now we can see straight away
that there are no gaps,
meaning that while this app is
running, it's keeping the cell
radio powered on continuously.
In fact, the regular updates
alone are enough to prevent
the radio from ever returning
to an idle state.
That shows us that the "Big
Cookie" model is a far better
approach to coordinating
our data transfers.
In this example, I've
bundled all of the
repeating transfers together.
And the intermittent transfers
have been largely replaced
with aggressive prefetching.
Obviously, you usually can't
entirely predict what data
users might need, nor can you
ignore either client or server
side changes that need
to be synchronized.
But you can aim to minimize
the number of radio state
transitions through a
combination of aggressive
prefetching, in addition to
batching and queuing any
transfers that aren't time
critical and bundling these
with user-initiated
time-critical transfers, or
those initiated from
the server.
The result is a significant
improvement in the amount of
battery drain your app
is responsible for.
In comparison to the previous
on-demand approach, the radio
is now idle nearly
2/3 of the time.
Even the active radio percentage
has dropped
significantly, thanks to an
improved download efficiency
as a result of transmitting
more data in each shot.
So taking the cell radio into
account, you can minimize the
battery impact associated with
your app's data transfers by
transferring as little
data as possible as
infrequently as possible.
Defragment your network access
by prefetching, batching, and
bundling your transfers, and
eliminate clients initiated
updates and polling as
much as possible.
The most important thing to
remember is that every time
you transfer data, no matter
how small, the radio is
powered up for nearly
half a minute.
So every decision you make
should be based on minimizing
the number of times
that this happens.
I dive into each of these topics
in more detail in other
videos in the Efficient Data
Transfer series of DevBytes,
including looking at ways you
can analyze your own data
transfer profile, and how to
implement some of these best
practices using simple code
patterns, as well as
implementing SyncAdapters
and Google
Cloud Messaging solutions.